[Music]
the phenomenon of illusion is quite
interesting because it tells you
something about how our perceptual work
our perceptual systems work and what
happens if they don't work and what
happens if they don't work is that you
get a variety of different experiences
that we would consider to be illusory
like hallucination and when you see
mirage's and dreams and so on and they
seem to project or convey a different
kind of reality or a different kind of
type of reality or to experience and now
the question is of course is that as
real as the reality of the waking world
is a different kind of reality or is it
just something that looks like reality
but isn't really alright so this kind of
phenomenon which you can which you can
investigate quite precisely by using
empirical means raises these very deep
philosophical questions about the nature
of the world in the nature of our
perceptual relations with the world so
to that extent illusions are very
interesting way and very very I think a
good example of getting into a
discussion of these fairly fundamental
questions and so do you have an example
of one such illusion which gets to these
fundamental questions well I mean you'd
start up with a very everyday experience
like dreaming right so everybody dreams
most people dream every night and you
are when you're dreaming you're
transported into a world which is very
very different from the from your waking
world you probably still think you are
you so there's some kind of continuity
but it's already very difficult to say
you know what kind of time you are in
you know are you you're obviously not
usually you don't dream that you are
that it's night when you're night right
she's obviously in a different kind of
time you might be in a space that's
completely different from your usual
surroundings so you have this experience
of being immersed into a completely
different world which once you are in
the dream looks exactly as real as all
of this stuff here yeah and now the
question is if you are so completely
taken in by that in this situation
why are you
more convinced that when you are in the
waking world as I think I'm right now
why are you more convinced that you are
actually really in touch with things
that are out there like a really exists
in space-time whereas in a dream where
it exactly feels the same but we would
think no in that case this is all just
something cooked up by your mind or
cooked up by your brain now so to that
extent that just a very everyday
phenomenon like dreaming gets you into
into those kinds of questions and this
is why philosophical traditions from all
around the world have focused on that I
thought that was a really interesting
theoretical problem and so you see these
those philosophical problems rather than
scientific problems which might be able
to explain these issues of illusion yeah
I think these two these two issues work
together right of course there is there
is the scientific question you know what
actually happens when we're dreaming
what kind of neurological processes are
involved how do they differ from the
kind of neurological processes that are
involved in the drape in the in the
waking world and so on so this is what
stuff science can tell us a lot about
yeah but what the the next question that
we want to ask then and that is where
the where the scientific question stops
is what is actually at the other end of
the representation what is being
represented right and that is something
which is a question that asks something
about what is that the other side of
empirical means and that is not
something you can investigate by
empirical means because the empirical
means only takes you so far yeah so to
that extent the the the scientific
questions have to end at a certain point
and at that point you really have to
start with a theoretical reflections
about the scientific results in order to
get any further and so you said that
those opposition's are all over the
world of sort of dealt with these
or like the phenomena of dreaming for
instance why has your work focused on
philosophically and how how they dealt
with this why you've worked your work
long for this philosophy that's right
yeah mmm is there something that you can
draw on to help explain these illusions
well the the I mean the phenomenon of
dreaming became very important in
specific parts of branches of Buddhist
philosophy where in general the whole
idea that the the world is in some way
illusionary it was became a major
intellectual focus and different
different Indian thinkers in particular
try two different ways of trying to
explain that and try to make sense of
what that means and one way of trying to
explain it was was saying look the
entire world is mental in substance
right so when we look at things so I see
this tent over there and there's
actually not and there's not an external
object out there let's rather what I see
here is some some construction or
concatenation of mental things of ideas
or different moments of consciousness or
something like that right so what
they've been trying to do there was
trying to develop a theory of the
external world that didn't assume that
the fundamental entities or the
fundamental constituents of reality are
bits of matter but bits of mind right so
that extent it's it's quite an
interesting way of trying to come up
with a theory that is the complete
inverse of we normally what we normally
think is the best way of explaining the
world namely first of all explaining the
material a bit and then see how mind
gives rise to that but they were trying
to do was the other way around they
started with the idea of consciousness
in mind is a primitive and then they try
to come up with an idea of how the
material word could arise from that and
where are your own thoughts on this do
you think mine comes before matter on
that
comes before mind ah well that's a good
question I think well if you if you
answer the question either way you'll
have to assume that there is some level
of reality that is fundamental and
everything comes from that right so we
have a kind of foundationalist picture
now I think that is probably is probably
not a satisfactory way of thinking it in
the end because what you end up with is
a set of entities such that the
dependence variation goes both ways
right so the material stuff determines
mental stuff and it mental staff
determines material stuff so it goes C
it goes both ways round in which case
you'll end up with a position where you
have no fundamental theory or you have
no rock bottom ontology to explain it
all so you end up with this kind of a
coherent is picture where everything
depends on some other things but there
are no completely independent things
yeah so I think that is the most the the
most satisfactory philosophical way of
thinking about it and so do you think
that means that we shouldn't trust our
senses or perception or we put too much
trust in them currently well it depends
on what you want them to do right
so I'd obviously put a lot of trust in
my senses if I want to get from here to
the other end of the field because my
sense has allowed me to navigate the
tents and not to trip over things and so
on so in to that extent they are they
are quite reliable but the question is
whether you would want to say that
therefore you can use them in order to
settle all question in particular
whether that you can use them in order
to find out what the one true account of
reality really is right and ever even
whether you should assume that there is
such a thing yeah so I think that is a
there is a difference in suffice you
might want to trust conventional reality
at the conventional level but not in the
ultimate level
and is this something that you've looked
at specifically within humans or do you
think that it crosses all species mmm I
don't really know I mean I not don't did
a very very clear idea about how animal
Minds work right I mean they they have
minds that are in many respects very
much like ours but also in other
respects very different from ours and so
if you take seriously a more the idea
that a mind might come before matter mhm
would you see this as changing how
humans relate to one another if you're
putting it with any human mind and an
individual hmm does this change
radically people's relations between
each other all I increase the difference
between how we think or the original of
reality yeah I mean this is quite
interesting to think about what what
kind of ethical implications these kind
these kind of pictures have because when
you when you're talking about what what
is what is the fundamental level of
reality and what kind of things are
fundamentally you're basically talking
about metaphysics you're talking about
can furniture of the world but the other
question is you know what what does this
kind of a bit of theoretical philosophy
what kind of normative implications does
that have and yeah so for example you
you might think that if you have the
idea that the world is what we live in
is fundamentally some sort of collective
mental constructions of different
perceivers then that immediately raises
the question to which extent the mental
states of the individual perceivers
determine or at least influence the
reality they perceive right so to that
extent what kind of world we live in
becomes a more or less direct
consequence of the kind of mental states
or the different people they are in the
world right and so to that extent you
would regard your own mental centers of
the mental states of others not not not
solely or not primarily as
representational of what is already
there but as in some for forming or
producing or bringing about what is what
is there right and then the ethical
implications of that are pretty clear
because you think okay so if you
actually if you mental state influences
as much as as it does on that picture
the reality that is around
then you'd better take good care or the
kind of mental states that you have and
that you project because that would be
immediately have immediate consequences
for the world you and other people will
perceive so do you think that there is
objective reality hmm well that is the
the the typical philosophers comeback is
you know that depends on what you mean
by objective and it means it depends
what you mean by reality right so I
think there is definitely objective
reality in suffice there's a shared
world in which we all live right so if I
you know I can see that red back over
there and if you look there you can see
the red back over there so to that
extent there they are some facts such
that they appear to all of us and to
that extent they are objective right
however the term objective reality is
also sometimes used in order to describe
a reality that is more fundamental or
independent of any perceivers right so
whether or not any minds were around in
the world there would still be specific
facts a-about what kind of fundamental
particles they are right so if we think
that human humans have never evolved
then the universe you know all there's
these bits of rock and so on would still
be flying around in space that kind of
objective I think it's a lot more
difficult to make sense of and to
philosophically justify then the kind of
objective in objectivity Labs have
simply flows from a shared social shared
consensual perceptions of observers and
so where has your work taking you most
recently what research you doing at the
moment all you've got a book coming out
and yeah I've just yeah I'm at the
moment I'm quite interested in the issue
of of solipsism and the question to
which extent the idea that there's only
one perceiver namely only me or early
you or or only a single mind exists to
which exert into which extent that
philosophical position which was usually
a god is completely crazy how that was
perceived and and debated in in various
philosophical traditions and it's quite
interesting that that this idea only
came up in there
different bits of history of philosophy
so for example the problem of solipsism
was never a big issue in ancient Greece
right so the ancient people thinkers
didn't really I mean either didn't think
of it oh I didn't think it was an
important problem whereas it did became
very important and quite strongly
debated in eighth century India and we
have a number of independent
philosophical treatises just devoted to
that problem so at the moment I'm
working on on a both systemic and
historical treatment that looks at the
question of solipsism and takes it
through this global history so starting
in ancient India and then moving moving
through an early modern stuff and then
the question of of solipsism became
interestingly also very very important
than in early analytic philosophy Vidkun
Stein in the Tractatus he very famously
made this very enigmatic statement that
solipsism is fundamentally right even if
we don't really know what he meant by
that so it's it's kind of an very
interesting and often neglected
undercurrent within the history of
philosophy and that that's what I'm
looking at at the moment and do you have
an idea of reasons why I appeared in
certain philosophies but didn't in
others that's a very good question no I
I've no I don't feel example have a
strong view of why the ancient Greeks
didn't ever figure it out right it's
pretty clear why it why first came up in
in ancient India because they that
occurred in a debate where people were
arguing okay so everything is mental
there are no external objects and then
the following question is of course yeah
but what about external minds right so
even if I think that this tent here
isn't isn't really externally then it's
only some bit of mind stuff so what
about a V what about your mind right are
you an external mind to my mind or are
you just a figment of my imagination
right so that thing that leads you
directly to the question of solipsism so
that it's clear how how that arose there
and then in in analytic philosophy
people earlier analytic philosophy
people also got quite interested in that
but for completely different reasons and
for example one one place where that
became important was in in early work by
early Carnap he tried to try to
construct
to theory of the world that was only
based on first-person experiences right
so he caught that methodological
solipsism meaning that the only a
primitive input he used for his theory
were his own experiences so and
everything else was for that matter
disregarded and then both external Minds
that external objects would have to be
created or constructed from that now so
there are various reasons why different
different parts of philosophy or
different thinkers were interested in
those problems but the fundamental
problem is of course always the same and
do you agree with a bit concerned
statement that it's fundamentally right
well if I I mean if I only knew
precisely what Wittgenstein meant by
that statement I would be much easier
for me to say whether whether he is
fundamentally right about it I think
what you need is in any case some kind
of account of accounting for the
appearances right so even if something
like solipsism is fundamentally right we
still need some coherent account of why
it still appears to us as if they're
external Minds right and so that is that
that is of course the the major question
to figure out in this context for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at IAI TV
you